but I do have a very special guest Nick
were gone who's the chief marketing
officer at attention yeah didn't be back
here it's always great to have you on
Nick and ascension has been a great
partner of the Chess Club for many years
now can you tell us a little bit about
what's new for that partnership sure so
now going off for years ascension in the
st. Louis chess club really Rex and I
created a program four years ago called
your move chess which is really about
funding chess in underserved communities
starting with the school districts of
Ferguson so there's about 20 schools in
Ferguson that we fund chess for and then
we expanded it out to other schools in
st. Louis and now even to Chicago and
Nashville and it's been a wonderful
partnership it's good for ascension
because we like to have a vital presence
in all of our communities and while
we're based in st. Louis we don't have a
hospital here so it's our way of staying
connected to the community and I think
it's great for the Chess Club - because
we're expanding its scholastic reach and
I know that's important too - Rex and
Jeanie and so it's really been a
fantastic partnership and in one month
from now March 7th we have our third
annual fundraiser to raise funds for it
at the Four Seasons
my wife Tien is really helping me chair
that this year and so we've already
exceeded our fundraising expectations we
want to continue to push through and and
create more fun so we could expand the
program wow you're getting your wife
involved and that's gonna make that
fundraiser even we're successful no
doubt I met her that fundraiser I know
she's fantastic
wow that was at the Icicle here that I
met her and also I'm really excited to
hear that you're expanding into Chicago
or Nashville yeah we have to a couple
schools in Chicago that we're in now in
Nashville as well and we have believe it
or not we have many other markets that
reach out to me all the time I get
emails constantly I'll get more today
after airing this asking can we have
your program and so we actually have
more schools in the queue that we could
fund and that's why our fundraiser on
March 7th is so important here in st.
Louis so the more every $2,500 we raise
we can expand to another school and the
more kids that play the more people that
agree playing chess them our sports
gonna grow and I think it's good for
everybody and here we see some wonderful
pictures yes Maurice Alejandro Ramirez
all they've all been a part of it be
coaching some of those kids inspiring
them from the Ferguson area and you can
understand now why so many school
districts want to have a program like
this yeah Maurice has been instrumental
at you as has Fabiano really all the the
GM community in San Luis is rally around
the program in a wonderful way and we're
so fortunate thanks to to Rex and his
generosity to be the epicenter of chess
I think not only in the United States
but around the world
I mean st. Louis now is the hub of of us
and international chess and and the
school districts in our area get to
benefit we're I mean we have 25 GM's
just in this area so they're not only
learning chess they're learning from the
best and and you know the Chess Club is
doing studies of the program and the
kids that are in it they're their
attendances up they've performed better
in their studies they enjoy it more and
they even are taking it home and
teaching it to their siblings and even
their parents and so it's good at school
and it's good for family as well that's
wonderful you know I also do a lot of
work in Philly with the chess there
especially with work with the girls from
Philadelphia chess Society and ASAP and
I see how much good it does tell me a
little bit more about this March 7th
fundraiser how can people get involved
whether it's a company that gets
involved or an individual so there's two
ways corporate sponsors and we have a
bunch of them or we're always looking
for more but we've had very generous
corporate sponsors that have really
helped us allowed us to then go ahead
and invite individuals from the
community to come and be a part of the
night so we have corporate sponsors and
you can reach out to me if you want to
be a part of that as well
Nick dragon at Ascension org and then
individuals who could attend and if you
go to the chess club's website you could
see a way to register online and and we
have you know last year we've had many
people attend who are regulars of the
Chess Club here who get the mails and
email and they come out and and so last
year was wonderful Fabi played blitz
chest and we auctioned off games for for
students to come up and play Fabi and
some of the other GM's and blitz and so
we're gonna do something similar this
year Eric Hanson will be attending we're
hoping that Fabiano will be there as
well as some other GM's and so we we
auction off games to play with the GM's
and it's really about the parents
auctioning off and having the kids that
come up and play and I may have played
last year and his Fabi checkmated me
twice in one game which is almost
impossible to do I actually were playing
blitz and he missed that he had
checkmate him
and then checkmated me again which wow
it's a great distinction well you know I
was glad to hear that the kids are
usually sponsored by the adults cuz I
didn't like this idea that they were
using their allowance putting the
sponsoring them and last year actually
Fabia was very gracious and he played
blitz against the other GM's who were
there including I think it was Eric
Hansen and maybe var and a few others
and you know a blitz imal against other
GM's it was very patient with us and it
was it was a great exhibition for people
to see the game up close at the highest
level oh absolutely and that's March 7th
and that sounds like a wonderful
opportunity to get to know some of these
grandmasters in a more social setting so
but we these types of events work is
that there's an entrance fee a
registration fee and the majority of
that I mean some of that might go to the
cost of food but the majority of that
will actually go to a program that's
what you're all the funds go to the
program essentially cup the coast cost
for the evening so okay what every
dollar raised goes right towards you
know for every dollar raised every
$2,500 raise the motor school district
can get the program so every single
dollar goes back into it and it is a
great chance whether you're a child or
adult like me to mingle with the best
players in the world as you know and
that's fun it for me playing with Bobby
or seeing him it's like taking batting
practice with Joe DiMaggio was a
lifetime thing it really sounds like a
steal so definitely look that up and get
to that fourth annual fundraiser for
your move chess on March 7 one last
question of course I know that you are
working with all of these students via
your next move program but what we're
trying to do here at the Karen's Cup is
inspire people that we need to get even
more girls and women into the game so
what are you observing in the years that
you've been supporting this are there
more girls and what do we need to do to
get more of them you know it's a great
point and I commend Rex and Jeanne for
creating the Karen's Cup and getting
more interest in the women's game I
think they start off playing at a
younger age and then as they get older
it seems that the girls tend to drop out
a little bit faster and the guys keep
playing we need to figure out how to
have them consistently play to adulthood
so that we have even numbers and I
noticed just watching the games I enjoy
these games more because they're more
decisive games at that at the super-g
men's level that's mostly draws here
we're seeing some I mean I'm looking at
arenas game and a few others really good
action if you like dynamic
just with decisive games this is
actually more entertaining I think and
whose repeat to win it I like arena I
think I think they're all wonderful
players I just like seeing dynamic
positions where there's a lot of action
on the board because that's for us
amateurs that's how we learn by seeing
these dynamic games well thank you so
much Nick for joining us
your next move fundraiser on March 7 it
sounds like quite the party but not just
a party but also for good it'll be a lot
of fun thank you again for having me